plus
[Musique]
ce sont des images qui depuis hier font
le tour des réseaux sociaux et n'en
finissent pas de choquer une vidéo sur
laquelle on peut voir un sanglier de 10
mois domestique et qui s'est échappé de
son enclos et qui sur un chemin temps de
sympathiser avec un groupe de chasseurs
l'animal nommé recul très habitués à la
présence humaine se comporte comme un
chien et essayent simplement d'obtenir
l'affection des chasseurs pour qu'il
joue avec lui lorsque tout à coup sans
raison apparente
l'un des chasseurs du groupe en dépit de
toutes les règles de sécurité primaire
des sites d'abattre de sang froid d'une
balle dans la tête et à bout portant
l'animal le propriétaire du sanglier à
la martin aujourd'hui très attristé
demande que ces actes gratuits et d'une
violence inexplicable soit condamné
alors faut-il interdire la chasse
alain est avec nous ce soir pour rendre
hommage à hercules alain merci beaucoup
d'être là ce soir alors je vous le dis
ces images jure on y amène tous pensé
toute la journée
vraiment c'est incroyable depuis que je
les ai eus j'y pense tout le temps c'est
ça un maillot aussi mais je vous jure
que c'est vrai y'en a plein qui veulent
pas les voir
j'ai pas pu je vous le dis j'ai pas pu
lire boire mais une fois parce que je
vois là je joue mais j'ai pas pu revoir
c'est difficile pour moi de les revoir
parce que quelque part c'est la fin
c'est la fin de ces la fin des reculs
quoi donc quelque part c
c'est difficile quand vous avez récupéré
cet animal qui était qui était condamné
puisque quelque part sa mère avaient été
tués
vous en avez récupéré trois petits comme
ça qui vous tombent du ciel ils ont une
petite journée à peine et puis vous
essayez de les laisser dans le parc en
pensant qu'une mère va les reprendre et
bats la nature ça se fait pas ça se fait
pas comme ça donc le lendemain vous
revenez et puis en a deux qui sont morts
le dernier qui est blottie contre les
deux autres et bien c'est le choix il ya
deux ans quand il a fait un bond
important c'est horrible ça mais ça je
l'aï su parce que le problème de
l'assassinât excusez moi de prendre le
mot mal bien sûr j'en ai pas d'autre
je suis d'accord et assassinats des
reculs c'était quelque chose que j'ai
appris bien plus tard il ya une omerta
au niveau de la chasse l'ate s'est
produit devant plusieurs témoins comme
vous pouvez le voir avec des gens qui
connaissent le parent qui connaissent
qu'ils connaissaient hercules qui
connaissent l'amour que je peux avoir
pour les animaux et personne n'a rien
dit
vous appuyez très très proche des reculs
c'était lui donniez même le biberon
c'est ce qu'on disait ça nous a vous
avez pas de show ils sont 27 vous êtes
son père vous aimait sa mère il a que
vous les gens qui aiment les animaux
peuvent ressentir ce que j'ai que j'ai
pu ressentir port hercule savez un
animal et il vous donne tout c'est vrai
non mais vraiment je comprends tout à
fait ce conserver et je sais pas si vous
avez des analyses sur thur et votre
chien alors je me suis exactement mis
dans cette situation là et je me suis
dit mais ça serait ce que je vaux
horrible parce que je peux reprocher aux
gens qui ont assisté à cette et à la
personne qui l'a fait aux gens qu'ils
ont su c'est pas de me rendais recul
ils n'ont même pas rendue ils ont ouvert
il y avait encore le le lait et le lait
pâtes que je venais de données du matin
tous les matins il avait sa gamelle
ils m'auraient appelé mardi monsieur
martin en a fait une bêtise pas dans les
conditions qu'elle a de la réalité dans
dix ans on a on a tué recul sur un sur
un groupe de sangliers qui partait et
que quelque part ça ça a fait que connan
qu'on savait pas c'est pas bon ça fond
ça peut excuser le geste mais la tuer un
animal gratuitement comme ça a été fait
en le quasiment le cas récent parce que
maman bébé il cherchait bien sûr c'est
ça ils vont chercher ses seins vous
savez ça voit pas très bien mais ça sent
énormément vient donc quelque part il a
fait tous les gens tac tac tac bac c'est
pas lui c'est pas lui donc on fait
qu'alain on vient sur les pattes arrière
un moment pour voir c'est pas lui donc
on continue les gens qui étaient là
d'ailleurs vous verrez au niveau de la
vidéo si vous l'avez écouté même disque
un moment pourquoi t'as fait ça courage
unis s'étaient pas à faire c'est un
geste pour moi qui ai pas pardonnable
mais ce qui est plus c'est l'omerta
ouais c'est ça c'est ça qui me gêne
c'est que les gens le sachent ans les
gens le y ont vu les gens ayant assisté
à la scène
dix bons on a fait une bêtise selon lui
rend son sens bien bien sûr lui rendre
c'est ça je vais vous dire quelque chose
monsieur hanouna
je me suis je vais je me serais fait
enterrer avec hercules tellement je
l'aimais ces dernières j'ai 60 ans c'est
incroyable ce que vous dites bah oui
j'aime mes animaux j'ai mon grand biniou
qui a été blessé par balle il ya deux
trois ans je lui ai fait un cercueil de
dôme être parent à les gens vont dire il
est compétent malades sont compris là
plutôt qu'à ce jour il n'a pas du tout à
fait au casque pas mal hein c'est
vraiment il a un amour pour ces animaux
que je comprends tout à fait toujours là
et quand je vous dis avec tout le monde
est dans le même état que vous ça ça a
vraiment sensibiliser tout le monde on
est on est tellement triste pour ce qui
s'est passé ça me fera parvenir hercules
mais ce soir si je suis sur votre
plateau c'est pour quelque part faire
justice à hercules qui soit pas mort
comme ça gratuitement sur 1 sur 1 sur 1
sur une personne qui a décidé que
c'était qu'un c'était qu'un sanglier ça
compte pas un sanglier sais rien bah
pour moi ça n'assure que raconte mes
services je vais vous dire une chose
j'ai eu plus de peine peut-être port
hercule que pour certaines personnes qui
pouvaient qui sont partis qui bien sûr
un terrain je comprends la peine quand
on perd un animal c'est moi pour moi les
ali sans ben là bas quand on perd ils
veulent un être cher aussi voilà parce
qu'un animal moi je moi je me suis mis à
votre place c'est vrai que j'ai j'ai un
jeu voilà j'ai une petite chaîne à la
maison de trois ans mais jugent la
considère pas comme quelqu'un de ma
famille cc voilà c'est je moi je
m'inquiète pour elle quand à barran et
ça c'est image là quand je les ai vus je
me suis mis je me suis imaginé que je
vois ces images sur mon animal mais
c'est ça cesse c'est traumatisant qui
s'est passé ça s'est passé comme ça se
passe souvent parce que ça fait 26 ans
qu'avec mon épouse ma famille mes
parents je vis ma passion je suis pas je
suis pas quelqu'un qui est né avec le
château du mont so j'ai deux enfants de
montreuil
ouais je suis l'ascenseur social comme
pourrait dire le président de la
république
tout ce qu'on a fait tout ce qu'on a mis
en place et travers mes parents à
travers ma femme à travers mes enfants
c'est la force du travail
regardez pas mes mains c'est des gens
c'est des mains de quelqu'un qui
travaille tous les jours les gens je
pense que du village aussi de la région
apprécié notre amour pour les animaux a
bien sûr bas pour les monuments
historiques
je suis sylviculteurs c'est donc je
cultive ma formation je suis le seul en
france à avoir relevé le défi forêt en
ayant syrie et boîte sur le long terme
on a six mille mètres cubes ont assez
pendant 10 ans on n'est que des passages
sur une propriété comme dans vous aviez
créé un grillage mais qui est vandalisée
à chaque fois aussi c'est
c'est continuer c'est que ces permanents
c'est toujours la même période je vais
vous dire hors période de chasse mais
clôture sont pas saccagés ni vandalisés
on arrive au moment de l'ouverture de la
chasse autour de chez nous il ya des
chasses commerciales faut que les gens y
viennent il faut qu'ils aient du gibier
donc le gibier se trouve éventuellement
dans le parc du château
qu'est ce qu'on fait on ouvre on coupe
j'avais croisé les chasseurs qui ont
fait ça ou des chasseurs non non qui ont
fait ça qui ont fait l'acte sur hercules
ouais non je n'ai pas croisé les
chasseurs n'ont porté plainte en
gendarmerie je tiens à remercier la
gendarmerie qu'est ce qu'ils ont dit le
gendarme ans ils ont fait leur boulot et
alors ils ont malgré qu'elle soit un
sanglier son ca leur boulot parce qu'ils
connaissaient recul ah ouais ils ont
bien le cssa les appels est aussi mais
derrière un gendarme il ya un homme bien
sûr derrière un homme il ya quelqu'un
qui est un animal il y avait quelqu'un
et des sentiments vous venez me parlez
de votre votre petite chaîne que vous
aimez demain quelqu'un vous tue votre
ipad chaîne gratuitement
bah vous avez quand même un petit peu de
haine au fond de vous-même un mais oui
voilà donc quelque part là dessus les
gendarmes ont fait leur travail
ça a été très compliqué parce que je me
répète un tout petit peu mais l'omerta
au niveau de la chasse ça tient c'est
sûr que les gens se tiennent commande
assistée moi ce que j'aurais aimé c'est
que les gens dénoncent l' acte bien sûr
mais disent voilà il ya quelque chose et
que ça soit la fédération de la chasse
qui verbalisent la personne qu'ils
aillent au combat au procureur de la
république et la remercie la personne la
vidéo avait pourtant été regardé par
l'office national de la chasse et de la
faune sauvage et personne n'a bougé
donc c'est je dis moi je suis pas et je
j'ai vu votre titre de des bâtons
anti-chasse je vais me permettre de
donner mon avis qui reste d'être
contradictoire par rapport aux propos
que j'ai vous tenir
j'aime les animaux mais je suis pas
contre leur enlever leur leurs principes
de chasse mais il faut que les gens
soient avec un respect de l'animal un
chien avec une éthique qui soient tenus
et arrêter cette escalade de chasse
commerciale qui fait qu'il va la
personne sa cravate
il faut qu'ils tuent et s'il faut que tu
la payes et fo qui tue et qu'on arrête
une fois que la personne a prélevé jeudi
prélever ses dires en ayant choisi
l'animal en ayant dit ben voila je
prélève tel type d'animal tout à l'heure
j'ai eu vocaux confrères de m6 on est
mort
malheureusement hier sa chasse est
encore autour du parc
une mère a été tuée cinq petits comme
hercule sont dans un ballot de foin ce
soir qu'est ce qu'on fait je les garde
je les prends voilà bernard moi moi
j'étais totalement bouleversé un pape
après les images en plus et envoyez cet
animal chercher l'affection qui s'était
en revanche on voit très très bien de
qui il s'agit est-ce que vous avez porté
plainte vraiment quelqu'un l'a alors
c'est en tout cas s'ils sont
identifiables quand même la personne qui
a tué recul est identifié et reconnu les
faits et alors qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire alors ben va pas suivre la voie
judiciaire normale c'est à dire mais
qu'est ce qu'elle risque je vais vous
portez plainte en belgique non mais le
parquet le pire c'est que le parquet a
classé d'accord abbaoui le si je suis là
ce soir
si la justice avait été moi je suis
toujours quelqu'un de respectueux de la
justice j'ai été élevé comme ça dans une
république où où je ne suis pas pour
faire l'omerta en disant que je vais non
la personne
je sais j'ai son identité jamais je la
dévoilerai pas ce que je veux pas non
plus qu'il ait des conséquences
hors norme il ya des gens qui
m'appellent de partout aujourd'hui savez
je pensais pas que ces horaires buzz on
dit le buzz maintenant mais des
retombées aussi violente et est aussi
nombreuse je suis content de ça je suis
content que le ministre de l' de la
deûle et de l'écologie et et relever la
voir la possibilité de dire je je veux
une enquête pour que cette affaire soit
enfin le ouverte et que le parquet ne
casse pas la sphère des reculs tu as
beau ça qu'on voulait aussi médiatisée
je vous le dis ce soir et vous soyez là
parce que ça nous a tous vraiment
rotonde cette affaire et ce meurtre
odieux a pour moi c'est un assassinat
j'utilise le même mot que vous vouliez
meurtre assassinat parce que c'est vrai
que je sais que j'ai vu de lui ne
pouvait même pas regardé les images d'un
des fidèles
elle menait de nous voir avant
l'émission me dit j'espère qu'on passera
pas les images du sanglier parce que je
peux pas les regarder en fait je suis
désolé du coucher un peu cet
accoutrement pour aller d'un truc
sérieux mais moi à chaque fois ça me
fait des palpitations tout ça parce que
au niveau des animaux on est en 2021
il ya toujours encore une injustice et
aujourd'hui les animaux ce sont les
seules victimes de tous tant qu'ils
n'ont pas le droit des process et des
salles victimes parce qu'ils ont les
mêmes sentiments ils ont ces voix-là et
votre votre petit qui a été tuée c'était
un sanglier domestique donc comme un
chien mais je veux dire c'est pas plus
horrible que tout parce que lui il
faisait confiance à l'humain mais c'est
pas plus horrible que tous les sangliers
qui se balade qui eux ne font pas
confiance à l'humain et ils sont aussi
tirés donc la chasse c'est quelque chose
en 2025 qui ne doit plus exister chasse
à courre ou chasse normal s'il peut
exister
j'ai les chiffres par exemple sur les
faisant 80 % des faisans qui se font
tirer cédé faisant d'élevage vous
comprenez ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'on les élèves ils sont habitués à
l'homme ils sont ils sont jetés et après
on les tire 80% donc ça veut dire que
c'est le plaisir de tuer avait pas de
réguler oui je voudrais vous laisser le
mot de la fin sur cette affaire scoop
qu'est ce que vous avez à dire ce soir à
nos téléspectateurs aux gens qui vous
regardent et aux gens qui ont tous vu
cette vidéo qui est horrible je voudrais
déjà le remercier de leur soutien parce
que c'est vrai que je pensais pas que ça
allait avoir des retombées si importante
et que les gens soient aussi solidaire
avec ne te je vais vous parler
franchement avec ma douleur avec notre
douleur au sol on est maire que la
maison j'ai 60 ans dans très peu de moi
les gens qui m'ont fait énormément de
mal si vous a versé une larme sur votre
plateau vont dire on lui a vu son
sanglier on lui a fait mal comprenez ce
que je veux dire parce qu'il savait
qu'il pouvait pas me faire plus mal ça
quand tu es mon animal vous savez il y
avait il ya un rapport entre l'animal et
l'homme qui à un moment c'est une osmose
vous savez pas pourquoi sûr qu'ils aient
besoin de lui
vous cherchez il vous cherche bah oui
c'est vrai je ne mens jamais vous saurez
série donc quelque part tous les propos
je vous donne je vous les donne avec mon
coeur j'ai rien préparé avant de venir
vous voir
on le voit vous êtes sincères ont parlé
j'aurais toujours avec ça moi ce que je
rêve c'est de faire un grand
park un grand parc naturel il ya plus
grand pat naturel au jour d'aujourd'hui
autour de paris j'aimerais avoir la
possibilité d'avoir un sanctuaire entre
guillemets que les animaux soient
sereins tranquilles les enfants ce soit
des enfants du 9-3 parce que j'y viens
où les eaux de partout puisse voir ce
que c'est que le brame du cerf puisque
voir ce que c'est qu'une mère suit et
parce que c'est beau c'est beau cyril de
voir un sanglier un sanglier c'est beau